Hello everyone, and welcome to today's Quick Start class on Sequencer Shot Creation.
My name is Brian Poole, and I'll be your authorized Unreal instructor throughout this
course.
Here's a quick look at what we'll be covering today.
In exploring Sequencer fundamentals, we'll examine some core concepts of Sequencer's
capabilities like what is Sequencer, what's a level sequence, and we'll discuss actor
persistence types.
That will be followed by an examination of core structures in Sequencer, we'll define
a few terms, and we'll compare Unreal Sequencer to the structure of film production.
In Sequencer features and tools, we'll take a look at Sequencer's interface, discuss
event management, curve editing, and set up a level sequence template.
Plus, we'll spend some time learning about Unreal cameras, their components, and primary
feature sets.
In hands-on shot creation and assembly, this section will focus on how to actually set
up a level sequence assembly and how it ties into the camera cuts track, followed by a
practical exercise.
And in final recommendations, we'll talk about level organization, folder structures,
and Sequencer best practices.
And then we'll look into some potential tips and resources.
Alright, let's get started.
Today's class will be utilizing the SEQ-10501 map level.
In the SEQ-90501-55 project file, it can be downloaded under content, courses, course
maps.
The project file you've downloaded contains items associated with four different courses.
We'll be examining the course SEQ-10501.
Our goal for this course is to start familiarizing ourselves with Sequencer and understanding
the basics of creating multiple shots within a single level sequence.
This project will utilize a level, contain a character, two cameras, and a camera cuts
track.
This first approach is the more simplistic of two Sequencer assembly methods where the
second method leverages multiple nested level sequences.
We'll get into more in-depth on nested level sequences during another course.
However, I'll promise you a sneak peek into what a nested level sequence setup looks like
just so you can understand the difference.
Once you've downloaded the zip file and extracted its contents, you should see the
SEQ-90501-55 project file.
This file was created in Unreal 5.5, so if you have an earlier version of the engine,
you should upgrade.
If you have a later version of Unreal, you'll have to convert the project file to Unreal
5.6 by following the prompts Unreal provides for you upon launching this project.
Now, the primary map should load automatically, but in case it doesn't, let's take a look
as to where you can find it.
Inside the contents folder, there is the courses folder.
This folder contains the course maps folder.
Within here, you'll find maps for all four courses within this project.
In case your level didn't open upon launch, let's double click on the SEQ-10501 map.
This will bring you into rural Australia.
Now, if you take a look around, this is really a great map, and it has some very realistic
models and textures.
What's even better is that it's highly optimized to run on most computers and GPUs with ease.
This map can be found in FAB in case you're interested in having it within your own library.
Now, if you're curious as to where the assets are for this level, they're located within
the assets folder.
There is a rural Australia folder, and it contains all of the individual component parts.
If we look over here in the Outliner, everything is nicely organized into folders and named
beautifully with a dedicated naming convention.
Now, the level sequence we'll be examining and ultimately recreating is located in the
course folder.
You'll navigate to the SEQ-105 folder, and then open course topics, and finally the
camera cuts folder.
Our level sequence is seq-cinicam-ex.
Now, if you'd like to take a look, double-click on the level sequence icon.
This will open the Sequencer UI and allow you to view the sequence by clicking on the
camera icon in the camera cuts track, and then by pressing play.
So click on this button, and press play.
Now this will show you two cameras being tied together through a camera blend in the camera
cuts track, but more on this later.
In our next module, we'll take a look at some core concepts behind Sequencer and understand
the theory of how Sequencer fundamentals operate.